- Des airs de calme
Jusqu'à ce qu'on s'enfonce
quelquus loin.ement
l'impression d'un lendemainde v.
Un lendemain de veille
particulièrement diffi
Le 15 novembre, à 4 heures
du matin, les Etchard ont dû
quitter le domic minutes.
La Ville entière a été évacuée.
Ici, l'eau s'est infiltrée
comme
Jaime n'arrivait pas
à y croire.
pour la première fois,
elle et sa familvenir
constater les dégâts.
"Hier, j'étais incapable
de marcher dans la maison",
lance ais tapis de boue
recouvrait entièrementle domicié
comment on allait faire
pour nettoyer."
Puis, au sous-sol, son fils
Jayden nous montoù l'eauoù l'eù.
"Tous les précieux souvenirs
familiaux sont morts noyés." Ja,
deux de ses quatre enfants
et ses parents, e.
À 69 ans, grand-maman
sort l'eau du sous-sol.
À 79 ans, grand-papa, lui,
fait ce qu'il peut.
qui s'installe, il faut brancher
l'électricité ledement
possible.
"Si le tuyau de la piscine
le, ça nous coûtera
plus de 50 000 $ juste
pour tout remplacer", dit re,
car ses assurances ne couvrentp.
Heureusement, la famille
vaillants amis pour les aider.
"Si n'importe qui m'avait dit
que nous allions
inonda mois
de novembre, alors que je vis
j'aurais ri." Mais rire, ce ne s
pour cette fois, alors que
le retour à l.
Les dernières inondations
d'envergure danslus de 65 ans.
En plus des maisons accidentées,
il y a les infrastructures
à reconstruire. Mais patience,
disentche sera colossale
pour la petite communauté
de 8000 résidents.
Radio-Canada, M